ouais il parlera qu'internet envahi
notre vie quotidienne nous en avons une
nouvelle preuve un petit supermarché de
la banlieue de montpellier propose
désormais ses produits dans le monde
entier grâce au net comme on dit ça n'a
pas été très facile de convaincre tout
le monde vous allez le voir avec
véronique gaglione et françoise mais
on ne sait pas laquelle il a passé la
nuit dernière sur internet enfin
françois bernard a réussi à valider sa
commande depuis son accident il est
devenu difficile de courir les magasins
là pour 10 francs il sera livré chez lui
bien qu'il ait pas la manipulation à
faire il ya pas le téléphone est un
coffre quelquefois je redescends
d'autrefois
fois toute façon des ascenseurs
ça sent pas de mes paquets entre pommes
de terre et salades un stand internet
est créé l'été dernier dans la supérette
de castelnou démonstration en surf sur
des idées recettes ont choisi parmi six
mille cinq cents produits alimentaires
photos et descriptifs sont là pour aider
tous ceux qui ne peuvent pas ou ne
veulent pas se déplacer
il n'y a pas de deux cibles privilégiées
je dirais même que une cible privilégiée
à l'heure actuelle ça pourrait être des
commerciaux qui ont des portables
ordinateurs portables qui sont toujours
à droite à gauche et qu'ils rentrent
chez eux n'ont pas le temps d'aller
faire les courses se connecte avec leur
téléphone portable sur internet et
peuvent faire leurs courses et il est
directement l'aï branché internet
copains du moins ce système me dépasse
l'effet de mode là
c'est un outil alors faire fonctionner
un outil demande une réflexion je sais
pas si si
les gens sont prêts à faire l'effort de
réflexion et ce n'est pas si facile de
renoncer après c'est son camembert dans
les rayons je n'ai pas besoin d'internet
pour les femmes et que c'est comme avec
les colts ça quel plaisir vous avez ici
à eugène ça j'aime me dire à la france
tout ça m'arrive de faire ça avec
internet dans l'instant fausse un peu
ridicule quand on est si proche de ne
pas venir le pari est audacieux
robert douce en l'épicier amateurs de
bons vins et de produits bio a investi 1
million de francs dans l'aventuré du web
aujourd'hui tous les magasins de
proximité en déperdition de chiffres et
puis même si on est on ne perd pas de
chiffres lui que les charges augmentent
et que tout augmente et bien nos marges
ne suffisent plus donc c'est une
question aussi de survie la petite
épicerie de castelnau a déjà livré une
fois aux états unis elle reçoit deux à
trois commandes par semaine seulement il
en faudrait 30 par jour pour que l'écran
du petit commerce reste honnête